mark german gave us a bombshell leak
claiming that apple is working on a
redesign of the ipad pro with a glass
back unfortunately it looks like the
upcoming ipad pro is most likely not
gonna come with that full glass back
redesign but according to 95 max sources
apple has actually been developing
prototypes with large apple logos that
are made out of glass the glass would
allow wireless charging power to be
distributed through it and the rest of
the back gonna be much more durable one
of the prototypes featured max safe with
stronger magnets than you get with the
iphone to prevent accidental damage
dylan dkt claimed that the future ipad
pros will feature a horizontally placed
apple logo on the back and i worked with
renders by shailesh to create some new
renders and the smart connector that we
currently have on the ipad pro is now
gone on my new renders because i fully
believe that the new ipad pro is gonna
be able to power the magic keyboard case
using reverse wireless charging